Um, I want to ask you about cuz I know
the Christian view is that
Jesus is both fully God and fully human.
Mhm.
Um, I want to ask when Jesus got
crucified, did his human nature die?
Yeah, so it's So really it's it's the
person
of Christ, the person of Christ dies via
his human nature. So, obviously if to to
die means the soul separates from the
body,
right? And so before taking on human
nature, he didn't have a body to
separate from. So, that's what death is
and so when he dies on the cross, that's
what's taking place.
Okay, so now that he's risen, is he Does
he just have his divine nature? That's
it?
Oh, yeah, so he doesn't he doesn't lose
his human nature when he dies. So
similar to us, like we don't we don't
lose our human nature when we die,
right? We just our soul just departs
from our body and moves to another
plane, right? So, in the same but you're
still human even in the next life,
right? So, um, so he still has both the
natures. He's still fully human and he's
still fully divine.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, yeah, cuz um,
I was
I was I used to be Christian and I
actually left Christianity
Mhm. and I went to Islam, but lately
I've kind of been
bouncing between the two.
Mhm.
I see. So So you've just uh, kind of had
questions building up, wanting some
clarifications on some things? Yeah.
Yeah. Well, yeah, I mean you're you're
we're an open book over here. So, if uh,
you know, if there's something that you
don't understand or you want to kind of
challenge or push back on a little bit
with Christianity, you're you're more
than welcome. I'd
try to my best to clear up some things
for you if I could.
Yeah, I've just been for now I've just
been reading the Old Testament because
um,
that comes before
Islam and it comes before Jesus and a
lot of Muslims will say that the Old
Testament was um,
you know, it was taught that to believe
in one God and to submit to God and then
when Jesus comes, um, that's kind of
when the message gets corrupted and
the [snorts] Paul like corrupts the
Bible. That's what I was told. Yeah.
So yeah, that um, Paul is the one that
introduced the Trinity. So I was like,
okay, let me go back to the Old
Testament to see what the Old Testament
says.
Yeah. And then I read the Old Testament
and
for me, I just I didn't really see it
align with Islam cuz there's some um,
things in the Old Testament that they
teach that doesn't
really align, like um,
>> Absolutely.
And uh, I was reading about a lot of the
prophecies about Jesus and I was kind of
like,
>> [clears throat]
>> okay, well this doesn't really match
with Islam. So now I'm getting a bit
confused between
>> Yeah.
Islam and Christianity. Absolutely. Now,
no notice this, sister. So,
you're you're you're doing exactly It's
it's funny cuz you're doing exactly what
the Quran tells you to do.
In chapter 10 verse 94, it says, "If you
are in doubt about what the Quran is
saying, then go and ask those who've
been reading the scripture before you."
Right? The truth is it's come to you
from your Lord so be not of those who
doubt. This is exactly what you're doing
with you wanted to investigate and so
you went straight to the previous
scripture. You went to the Torah
and you're like, "Wait, hold on a
second. There's prophecies here that are
about Jesus
that clearly go against Islam,
right? And these are these are things we
can't deny. We we see it. You don't even
have to be a Christian to see it. Like
yeah, this is talking about Jesus. This
is describing what happens to him,
right? And it doesn't go with Islam.
So,
there's there's there's only one
conclusion to this. It is that
although the Quran claims to be in line
with these with these scriptures, when
we actually see and check for ourselves,
we see that the Quran is actually not in
line with them and therefore
it's false because it's going against
the revelations of God.
Yeah.
Yeah. That's that's the That's the
Islamic dilemma. That's what we call it.
Yeah, it's just um,
cuz when I left Christianity, basically
like it was told that
um,
all of the prophets that came before
Jesus, they basically just taught to
like
believe in one God and um,
submit to God and for me that was like,
okay, that makes sense. That was simple,
but then
I didn't really read the Bible, so I
would say I wasn't really the strongest
in it, but now that I'm reading the Old
Testament, Mhm. kind of getting a bit
Yeah. confused, yeah.
Yeah, there's more there's more to it
than just monotheism. Like this this is
what Muslims like to propagate and like
it's just that that's [clears throat]
the only thing. No, that's not. Cuz
look, even the Bible says in in the book
of James, um, in his epistle,
he's an apostle of Jesus. James says
that you believe in one God, you do
well. But even demons believe and yet
they still tremble, right? Demons
believe, jinn. They they believe that
there is one God. Whoop-de-do, you know?
What is Where is your heart posture? And
there's more to it than that. You have
to believe in the right God and in his
right message, which he testifies of his
son, Christ, the Christ, the Messiah,
you know? So,
this this is why this is extremely
important. Even when you look into the
Old Testament and you look at who the
true God is, the one God is, Yahweh,
right? The God of Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob, and he tells us what's going to
happen
with the Messiah.
Yeah.
>> And anybody that says otherwise is in
falsehood.
It's simple.
That's how we can pick out false
prophets is if they're contradicting
what God has said before.
Yeah.
Right? So So where So let me ask you
this. Where Where are you
Where Where are you now? Like what what
Where are you Where is your position now
when you when you've seen this and
you're you're noticing this stuff,
do you still
think Islam is is still true even though
it's going against the Torah? Like what
what are your What are your thoughts on
that?
Um,
well, the thing is when I like bring it
up about the Torah,
um, like I was talking to another Muslim
streamer who's like really popular. He
does um,
streams and
>> Mhm.
I was talking to him about the Torah and
he basically just said, "Well, you know,
it's corrupted and you can't really
trust the Torah because we've lost
the original um,
manuscript. So like we don't know what's
changed." But then
>> Mhm.
I don't know. It was kind of weird
because then he'd also refer to like to
the Torah sometimes to tell me
>> Yes. what they
>> [laughter]
>> believe. So then I was
>> Yeah. Not in a rude way, but I was
telling him like, "How do you know
that's not correct? Like you can't pick
and choose." So, I don't know. It was
just it was kind of confusing for me.
Uh,
sister, you are you're right on it.
>> [laughter]
>> You are right on it. They They say that
the Torah and the Gospel are corrupted,
but then when it's convenient for them,
they go to the Torah and Gospel to try
to prove what they believe and to help
their belief system.
You know?
Oh, did he just text me? Did it just
scratch you? See, that's why I don't
trust cats, man. As soon as you say
they're cute, I don't trust cats. My My
wife has been asking like, "Can we get a
cat?" No, we can't get a cat. No cats,
man. No, they are cute, though.
>> [laughter]
>> Shoot, man. I see right past that
cuteness, man. No way.
But they they pick and choose the parts
of the scripture they want to believe in
when it's convenient for them. And
anyone with a thinking honest brain can
see how dishonest that method is.
That's like me trying to say that the
Quran is false, right? But I go into the
Quran pick and choose what parts I like
that seem to agree with me and I
eliminate and erase the others that
clearly disagree with me. You know,
that's that's just that's not a good
truthful method to come to truth.
Yeah.
Yeah. So that that and and the Quran
also speaks against that. The Quran says
in chapter 2 verse 85, it says, "Do you
believe in part of the scripture
while rejecting the rest? Those who do
so will be disgraced in this life and
awaits for them the most heinous torment
in the hereafter." That's chapter 2
verse 85. So even the Quran speaks
against cherry pickers. He hates when
people cherry pick at scriptures.
>> [snorts]
>> You know? So it's it's just there's no
way out of it. There There's no way out
of
um, like if if you're if you're going to
be a Muslim,
you have to contend with the fact that
the Quran points to these scriptures as
true scriptures and true revelation of
Allah
while at the same time contradicting
them and there's no way out of that.
There's you're in a bind.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah.
>> So let let me ask you this. What are
When you said that you were looking at
some of the prophecies about Jesus that
seemed to contradict Islam,
do do do you have some that come to mind
that you that kind of stuck with you or
that you can remember?
>> [snorts]
>> Well, um, what made me question Islam
first was about
um, the covenants in the Old Testament
and I think it's Jeremiah 31
and it talks about there will be like a
future covenant. Yeah. Wait, let me get
it cuz um, I wrote it down.
Yeah, that's good. Jeremiah 31.
Uh, 31:31 where it talks about the new
covenant that God's going to come that's
unlike the old covenant, yeah.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, but um,
what it said, "I will put my law in
their minds and write it on their
hearts. I will be their God and they
will be my people." Mhm. And then
>> um,
it says like, I think it's Ezekiel
Ezekiel, um, 37.
>> And it says that I will put my spirit in
you. And I was kind of thinking that I
think like in Islam, um, that might be
considered like That's shirk. Yeah, cuz
God doesn't wouldn't put his spirit in
>> [snorts]
>> Exactly. Exactly. All of All of that
would be shirk. All of that would be
blasphemy. To say that God, his own
spirit, is being placed within human
beings.
That That goes directly against uh
the core of what Islam teaches in and
tawhid, what they what they call tawhid.
It goes strictly strictly against that.
Absolutely.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Go go keep going if you if you had
other things. I'm just saying like this
these are things that we're see we're
seeing how the God of the of the Torah
is different completely different from
the God that's described in in Islam in
the Quran and Hadith.
Yeah, that was cuz, um,
it's kind of believed that like when
Jesus came, he taught Islam and
submission to God in his own
his purpose was to bring back the
Israelites cuz they fell into idolatry.
So, he was supposed to bring them back
to believing in one God.
But, um,
and I guess they'd say that this is
corrupted. But, when I read the New
Testament, uh, well, the belief is that
Jesus like fulfills the covenant so that
they so they no longer, um, have to obey
the Levitical laws. Mhm. And a lot of,
um,
that I'm kind of like a bit confused
from the Muslim view because, um,
Jesus predicts that the temple's going
to, um,
get destroyed. So, it's like if
if Jesus came back to told them to
submit to God, but the temple gets
destroyed, then how would they continue
their sacrifices? And I think the
Christian view is that like Jesus
becomes that
the lamb the sacrifice that they like
have to their sin for. Yeah.
>> something that I was like
kind of confused on as well. Okay. So
so, um, from from the Christian
perspective,
this is a Matter of fact, let me
you have your Bible on you or do you
have a you have it written down? You
have a How are you How are you reading
the Bible?
On my phone. On your phone? Okay. All
right, no worries. So,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you some some passages here.
And, uh,
about the Messiah in line of what you
just asked, okay? About the the the
temple
um, being destroyed and everything.
Okay?
In Daniel chapter 9,
it actually refers to this
and tells us why the temple is
destroyed.
>> [clears throat]
>> I'm going to show you.
Okay.
>> just give me 1 second while I get these
ads off of this and I'm going to share
my screen so we can all read it
together.
Why is this on my screen?
Please leave. Okay, there we go.
All right, now let me share the screen.
Oops.
There we go. You can see it?
Yeah.
Awesome. Okay. So,
uh, let me just do this real quick.
I'm actually sharing the side.
Freeze.
Okay.
So,
so this is Daniel 9,
chapter verses 26.
I meant to put to 29, but we'll see.
So, and after the 62 weeks, an anointed
one shall be cut off. Anointed one means
mashiach in the Hebrew. That's Messiah.
All right, so after 62 weeks, an
an anointed one, a mashiach,
will be cut off
and shall have nothing.
And the people of the prince who come
who is to come shall destroy the city
and the sanctuary. So, when does this
happen? This happens after the anointed
one, after the Messiah is cut off.
And shall have nothing for no reason.
What What is the
What's the 62 weeks referring to? So,
that's referring to uh the years in
which it's it's a time frame. And it's
it's actually quite quite deep and a
little complicated cuz for us we we
understand 62 weeks like we know what a
week is, 7 days, you know, weeks. But,
this um this is actually multiplied. So,
it's kind of hard for me to explain it
in a quick way, but, um, if you if you
if you look into
uh the 62 weeks explained, right? And
there'll be uh articles and videos up
here that'll that'll help cuz it's uh
it's basically multiplying like 62 by 7,
you know, like set is 62 uh
62 sevens, I think it is. So, it's by
years, right? So, a a week like we know
a week is 7 days, so a week here is
counted as 7 years. That's what it's
supposed to be equal as. So, 7 years.
So,
um, so this is a time frame in which the
Messiah comes and when he will be
unalived. Now, the time frame matches up
to the first century.
In the first century, the Messiah comes
and is cut off. He's unalived. He's
killed.
And and shall have nothing, right? And
then as a result, what happens?
The people of the prince who is to come
shall destroy the city and the
sanctuary.
It shall It's It's end shall come with a
flood and and to the end there shall be
war. Desolations are decreed.
All right? And he shall make a strong
covenant with many for 1 week. And I and
for half of the week,
he shall put an end to sacrifice and
offering.
And on the wing of abomination shall
come one who makes desolate until the
decreed end is poured out on the
desolate. Now, this is Notice this.
So, you have the We have the Messiah
that dies. He's cut off from the land of
the living.
And then the sent the sanctuary and the
city is destroyed. That's what happened
in 70 AD. Yeah. So, we know that the
Messiah came before 70 AD.
And something happened to where God's
judgment on the city
has it destroyed and this is why. Cuz
they unalived the Messiah.
Cuz they re- rebelled against him and
cut him off.
But then it's it it says that the
Messiah puts an end to sacrifice and
offering.
Yeah.
Why? Because he himself is the sacrifice
and the offering. He's the last one.
He's the ultimate sacrifice and
offering.
So,
this is demonstrating that when we look
at Jesus and he predicts the destruction
of the temple and the destruction of the
city,
it's at it's a judgment on Israel
because they rejected him.
They rejected the stone, right? He's the
stone that the builders rejected. And
they cut him off. He he died
for us.
So, all of this is within prophecy. That
is why is why I brought this here. Well,
your your question is based in prophecy
and what the script and what the
scriptures prove.
You know?
>> Yeah.
So, this is it all ties in. The Bible
all it it all ties in. And which is the
crazy part. Even even the gospels tie in
with Daniel. Daniel's tying in with the
other
prophets. All of it ties in and is one
thread, like one thread of the same
thing
until you get to the Quran. The Quran is
something completely opposite.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, for, um,
yeah, cuz I was looking at continuity
between like the Old Testament and the
New
the New Testament and then, um, the Old
Testament and Islam. And when I left
Christianity, the reason was because,
um, you know, I was told that like, "Oh,
in the Old Testament, they believed in
one God." You know, they say like, um,
Hear Hear, O Israel, your Lord is one.
And then like in
Islam, they believe in one God. So, that
was one. And then, um,
in Judaism, they have like fasting days.
They have, um,
rituals like purity laws. And then Islam
also has purity laws. So, like when I
looked at the Old Testament, I looked at
the rules that they had, I was like,
"Oh, these rules must have been what we
we have we have to follow." And that's
why Islam has like all of these, um,
things like how you eat, how much times
you pray. Like Islam and Judaism both
have a
They both have like a law compared to
Christianity which doesn't really have
one. So, I thought that this is why, um,
cuz like in Islam, it's taught that
Jesus didn't actually come to get rid of
the law, but Paul and, um, some of the
apostles kind of were the ones who
abolished the law. So, that's why I
thought Islam was actually the true
continuation of the Old Testament. Yeah.
It It's actually quite interesting
because even the Quran says that Jesus
came to
and and to change some of the laws of
the Torah.
Like the Quran actually says that in
chapter 3 verse 50. Let me just show you
the verse really quick.
In In chapter 3 verse 50 of the Quran,
>> [clears throat]
>> Jesus comes and he says that he's come
to make lawful some of the things uh or
um make
make lawful some of the things that were
forbidden to them and then and vice
versa.
So,
uh
if if if this is a teaching that Jesus
is not supposed to
change [snorts] the law,
well, then Muhammad got that wrong,
right? Let's see this really quick. So,
here's the verse. Here's chapter 3 verse
50.
>> [snorts]
>> And this is Jesus speaking. And I have
come confirming that which was before me
of the Torah
and to make lawful to you part of what
was forbidden to you.
And I have come to you with a proof from
your Lord. So, fear Allah and obey me.
Right? So, if a Muslim is coming and
trying to argue that Paul is a false
messenger who corrupted the message of
Jesus because he teaches that Jesus
changed the law,
then that would mean that Muhammad falls
under that same scrutiny cuz in the
Quran it's literally teaching that Jesus
came to change some of the laws of the
Torah.
Yeah.
>> So, so that would be inconsistent. Now,
to be correct on this, Paul is not
teaching that Jesus came and changed the
law. He doesn't teach that. He teaches
that he he completed and fulfilled the
law, which is exactly what Jesus said he
did.
Jesus said he came not to abolish it,
but to fulfill it, right? To complete
it.
>> Yeah.
Right? And that's what Paul is saying.
Like Paul affirms that Jesus did just
that, that he fulfilled the law. And so,
a lot of people
misconstrued Paul's
teachings, but look at what he teaches
about the law here. He doesn't say that
we
like we destroy the law or anything. He
says we uphold the law by our faith. Let
me just show you that really quick. This
is Romans chapter 3.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> chapter 3 verse uh let's see.
Let's see here.
Do do do do do.
Let's let me do it this way. Control F
for verses at.
Uphold
the law.
Yep, there we go.
All right, here we go. See, we we like
to we like to get in our Bible. I like
you, too. You like to you like to get
into the scripture. I like that. Yeah.
[snorts]
So, this is what says this is what Paul
says in verse 31. He says, "Do we then
overthrow the law by this faith?
By no means. On the contrary, we uphold
the law."
So, this accusation that that Paul is
against the law is such a false
accusation against him. And they they're
not understanding his writings in
context.
So, what he's what he teaches is that
the law is not what saves us. You
abiding by the law being under It's not
that's not what saves you. It's your
faith that saves you, not works of the
law.
Because if you if you rely on works of
the law to save you, you fail. You break
the law all the time. Yeah.
>> That's why Christ had to come and
fulfill it.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay.
So, I hope I hope that All right, does
that help a little bit?
Yeah, definitely.
For sure. For sure. You uh Did you have
some questions on the atonement on the
atonement of Jesus? Were you confused
about his atoning sacrifice?
Um well, I think I had um
Let me see.
Let me see if I can find it. Okay. No
worries.
No worries.
>> [clears throat]
>> I I appreciate you coming with uh these
genuine questions. We don't It's it's
rare that we get people that come
genuinely, you know? Some people come
just to argue and fight, but you're
you're really seeking and trying to
understand, so I appreciate that.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, I definitely want to um find the
truth.
Yeah, amen. Amen.
Yeah, I had
Well, I was confused on atonement, but
um I understand it now cuz I've been
doing research.
So, you so you're you're good on that?
Yeah.
Okay.
So, so then so what what is it then I
guess
that
is uh
I guess still keeping you at bay from I
guess accepting or I guess fully Christ
and his atoning sacrifice.
W- I- I- Is there s-
Are there things that's still holding
you back that's keeping you
still tied to Islam um even after seeing
the prophecies, even after seeing like
the the continuity of the Quran is is
not with the Torah and the and the
gospel.
W- What is it that's keeping you away?
Well, um
at first it used to be the Trinity, but
um
as I've been reading the gospels like
cuz I thought that I thought that the
Trinity was kind of like something that
was invented, but then I was reading the
gospels, I was reading what Jesus was
saying, and I was like
when I was reading how he was talking, I
was thinking like
he doesn't really sound like prophet.
Mhm. It does like he definitely does
sound like he is calling himself
Like something he would say things like,
"I give eternal life." which I think
would be considered like shirk in um
Yep. [laughter]
Yep.
I do believe Well, do I believe Jesus is
God? I believe that he's like
Mhm, I don't think he's a prophet.
Mhm. You think he's more than that, huh?
Yeah, but for me like God like
especially in Islam like God is
something that you can't even like
conceive. Like it's the highest
>> [snorts]
>> being, so like
Mhm. Yeah, I don't know. I I imagine
that though, sister. Imagine
cuz you're right, God is the greatest
conceivable being, you know? Goes beyond
our imagination and comprehension.
And in the gospel, in the Torah, it
teaches a God who is willing to
condescend to come to us and have
relation with us so that we can know him
and be made right in him.
That's that's the type of God that the
Torah and the gospel preaches. The God
Like literally like you were reading
in the in the new covenant, God says
that I will put my spirit in you.
Yeah.
>> Right? And put my put my law in your
hearts. And I will be your God and may
you you will be my people. Like this is
the God who is incomprehensible, who is
way beyond He doesn't even have to have
relationship with us, but he offers
himself to us.
He's He He doesn't stay away. He's not
distant, but he's relational.
Right?
>> Yeah.
Yeah, I've heard your argument about um
the reason why God had to be
three is because of like his nature and
love being in his nature. Mhm.
I don't know if this sounds bad, but
for me it's kind of weird to like think
that God is
not loving, but like
um
cuz like with human beings like when we
love someone, it's typically because
like we get not get something from them,
but like we have a um
There's like an exchange.
>> unconditional. That's what I meant. So,
when I was reading the Bible like and I
was doing research and like in the Bible
God is like unconditionally loving. It's
kind of weird to think.
I don't know cuz Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I don't know. Well, let me
let me ask you Are you
Are you a mother yet? Do you have kids?
No, I'm not a kid.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay, okay, cool, cool, cool. That's all
right. Okay, save that for later. Um
>> [laughter]
>> But uh but here here's here's something
that is that's interesting.
Um Are you close with your mother?
Yeah. Yeah? All right, awesome. Let me
ask you this. Did you do anything
before she loved you?
Mhm, I guess no. I'm just a kid, isn't
it? So. Yeah, you're just a kid. You
didn't you you Matter of fact, you
didn't really
give her materially anything, right? You
couldn't offer her any money or a safe a
house or you pay your Matter of fact, it
cost more to have you, you know?
She had to get more resources to get you
know, to take care of you. Like you cost
money. You know what I'm saying? But
yet, your mother she loved you. She
cherished you. She raised you. You
didn't have to do anything or say a
word, and she loved you already anyway
because you're her child. Unconditional.
Right? And so,
in a very similar way, this love
like a mother to her child, a father to
his child is this actually is a love
that is reflected
from our heavenly Father.
From our God. It comes from him.
This unconditional
uh intentional
relationship and love originates in God,
and we are just reflections of that.
Yeah. You know? So, I I
I hope it's not too hard to imagine, but
we we He's given us little glimpses that
we can look at and say, "Wow,
as as a mother loves her her daughter,
as a father loves his son, even more so,
the Father, our heavenly Father, loves
us." But the Bible talks about where
Jesus is in a beautiful sermon on the
mount. He's talking about us not
worrying, all right? And and not being
afraid because our Father in heaven,
he's our Father. He takes care of us. He
loves us. He says he dresses the lilies.
He decorates the flowers. He feeds the
sparrow, the birds. He gives them food
and nourishment. How much more does he
love you? How much more will he take
care of you?
You know?
So,
that's the
that's the God we serve.
And he doesn't have to be.
He doesn't He could be distant,
deservedly so cuz we're rebellious. We
sin. We uh we do heinous things. We are
mean to each other, rude. We we curse
each other. We curse God. We do what we
want. We choose things over him. And yet
still, he gives us nourishment. Still,
he takes care of us. Still, he steps in.
and when and that moment when we say,
"Lord, if if you are the true God, show
me you." He shows up. He guides us. He
takes us exactly where we need to be to
know who he truly is so that we can have
true relationship with them, true
connection.
That's how good That's the gospel.
Yeah, I think it is I don't know. It
felt
I don't want to say that it felt fake,
but like
cuz like if if you talk to most people
that aren't religious and you ask them
like describe God, I don't think anyone
like unconditionally loving. Mhm.
>> So,
I don't know. It was always a It was
always a weird thing.
Yeah.
>> oh God, it was like really really really
loving. I don't know.
>> I mean it literally the Bible says that
while we were still sinners, Christ died
for us. That this is how God showed his
love. It says, "God showed his love for
us in that while we were still sinners,
while we're enemies of God,
Christ died for us."
You know? So, for forget what someone
who doesn't know who God is says. God
has revealed himself as an
unconditionally loving God.
That's that's how That's That's how he
revealed himself.
>> [snorts]
>> You know?
>> Yeah, I was
I was saying that when I was doing
research on like the old covenants and
the difference between how it works in
Islam and Christianity cuz in
Christianity when God makes a covenant,
he doesn't take them away like
he doesn't break the covenant in
in Islam. If you break the covenant, God
takes away the covenant. So, it was like
the way the covenant the covenants work
in the both religions is like very
different. Very different. You you have
Allah in the Quran, if you're faithless,
he'll be faithless.
You know? If you love him, he'll love
you. That's literally what the Quran
says. He loves those who love him,
right? He He loves the believers, not
the unbelievers.
Um and so, you have to love Allah first.
You have to If he makes a covenant with
you, if you break it, he'll he'll break
his end of the bargain. He'll give it
up. But God, he's faithful even though
we're faithless. When we fail and are
untrustworthy, he remains trustworthy.
He remains trustworthy. So, it's it's a
completely different God. It's a
completely different God at its at the
core. There's no way the God of the
Bible, the God of the Old Testament, and
the gospel
is the same God of the Quran and and the
Hadith. There's no way.
It's impossible. There's no continuity
in character, in theology,
in morality. There's no continuity.
Yeah, I do agree like
some people Muslims will say that it's
the same God, but I I don't agree that
it is like they are different. I would
definitely say.
It's just about which one is the right
one.
So, I
correct me if I'm wrong.
I'm a It says Nakabi with questions.
I'll just I'll just say Nakabi, okay?
That's all I'll just call you. Is that
okay?
Yeah. Okay, I won't say your name, okay.
So,
>> [clears throat]
>> correct me if I'm wrong, Nakabi.
Am I wrong in saying that in your mind
and in your heart, you
tend to lean towards the God of the
Bible as being the true God?
Am I wrong on that?
I think when it comes to like
the morals and ethics, I like the God of
the Bible, but when it comes to like
thinking about what God is, like
just being one you can't see God like
all powerful,
like
all of that basic stuff, I'm more
leaning towards Islam. So, it's like
split in between the two.
So, so let's let's talk about that then.
In what ways do you believe that the God
of the Bible theologically, if you're
talking about what God is, all powerful,
all knowing, all this stuff?
In what ways do you do you
do you see a lack where he doesn't meet
the criteria of being,
you know,
of of meeting the criteria of being God,
what God is supposed to be?
Um well, there's one there's one verse
that a lot of people would point to like
it says in Genesis I think that when God
on the seventh day he rested and then
like obviously God's not supposed to be
tired. So,
God resting, but I'm not sure if that's
just like more of a metaphor than like
God actually being tired. Um so, Yeah,
the the the Hebrew word means to cease.
Like so, he just like he was working and
creating and then he he ceased creating.
He just rested from creation, not that
he was tired.
So, so people are misunderstanding that.
He's not He's not
He's not fatigued.
Yeah,
one way I think God said that like he
regretted making humanity because
>> [clears throat]
>> sin And in
Yeah, in Genesis in Genesis 6 it says
that he repented from making humanity
that he made [clears throat] man.
And and this is actually interesting
because what we're seeing here is
in the Hebrew the word repent means to
to turn away, to turn from. And so,
uh really what's going on, you see that
Genesis 6 is describing man as being
continuously evil.
And so, he turns from dealing with them
one way and deals with them another way
by wiping them out except for Noah.
So, instead of being patient with them
and continuing to let them go on,
he
turns from them and wipes them out with
the flood.
>> [snorts]
>> So, it's it's not it's not like a oh
man, I made a mistake type of
repentance. It's a it's a it's a you
know,
a directional change of I was dealing
with you guys this way, now this is how
I'm dealing with you.
Okay.
Yeah. And um I do believe that the
father is
like the all powerful like God you can't
see that obviously that it just it's
just when it comes to Jesus being God.
That was the moral.
So, okay. And now but with Jesus being
God, it seems like you don't you don't
have a problem with that anymore.
Right?
Yeah, it's cuz like for me
I tried to when I'm
when I'm getting into something like I
want to be able to like conceptualize
it. So, like Jesus being fully God and
fully human, that's something that I
can't conceptualize. So, it's like
really hard for me to believe in that.
You're trying to conceptualize God?
Yeah. That's impossible.
You're going to lose your mind. What?
>> [laughter]
>> If you try to If you if if if you serve
a God that you can conceptualize,
then that isn't the true God.
Right? The like if if he's unlike
anything in creation and incomparable to
creation, then how can we conceptualize
him unless he reveals himself?
The only thing we can know about God is
what he reveals about himself, right? We
we can't make him up. We we you know?
So,
God God cannot be known unless he makes
himself known. He cannot be
conceptualized or no, you know, unless
he reveals himself. That's the only
thing that we can even conceptualize
what God reveals about himself.
So, I I
I don't [snorts] I don't think it's fair
on your part like to yourself to say,
you know, if if I can't conceptualize
God in certain way, then I can't believe
that cuz
it's God. God can't be conceptualized by
definition.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, I'm starting to understand like
the father and the son distinction more
and that
like
the son entered humanity. Mhm. And um
was fully God and fully fully human.
Like the human side was obviously Jesus.
And um
Yeah, slowly I've been like
understanding it more and especially
like reading the gospels, that
definitely helps cuz Jesus does just say
just say and especially like John,
that's one of the strongest ones. Like
it talks about
the son and like what his purpose was
and everything. So, that does help. So,
slowly starting starting to understand.
Yeah, that's good. That's good. E- even
even in the in the other gospels as well
like Mark and Matthew like Jesus talks
about how he's
you know, the the son of man who judges
on the day of judgment, who's going to
come in his with with his glory, with
the angels, and decide who goes to
heaven and hell. Like Jesus, this is how
Jesus talks about himself.
In the gospel, there's any
and as you have already seen it, there's
no way in the world
that he can be a good prophet speaking
the way he's speaking if he's merely a
prophet.
>> [laughter]
>> Ain't no way. Not not Quranically, not
Islamically, and not biblically.
You know? So, unless Jesus is God in the
flesh,
then he's a blaspheming lunatic who's
lying and just crazy making crazy
claims.
And the other the other spec the other
end is that he's God in the flesh
telling the truth about himself.
You know? Yeah, I agree. Yeah, I do like
when I'm when I'm reading what Jesus
says, I try to imagine like Muhammad
saying the same thing just to see just
to see if it would be shirk. And
there are some things he says that I'm
like
like yeah. Yeah, can't say that. Can't
say that and be a good prophet of God,
you know? Can't do that. That'll be
That's blasphemy right there. That's
shirt. That's shirt.
So,
um well, sister, you you know, it's it's
you're on the you're on the right track.
You're on the right track. Um if you
have any questions, I don't care what my
topic is on a live stream,
you can come up and you can you can say,
"Hey man, I'm here with more questions
or clarifiers, whatever it is. Let's
let's talk. I don't care, okay?"
Okay. All right. So, don't don't build
don't be away too long. Keep studying.
Keep praying. God is leading you to the
truth. He's guiding you. Your heart is
open. Do not change. Stay this way.
And um and God bless you. You blessed me
with this conversation. It was awesome.
Can I just ask one more quick one? Just
a minute.
Yeah, um
I just wanted to ask, why would God
create humans if he knew they were going
to sin and he knew he knew that a lot of
them were going to go to hell? Mhm.
Yeah, so well, one, God God is
relational.
He's relational.
So,
um
to in order for relationship to exist,
there has to be free choice on both
sides. Right? You have to be be able to
freely choose the other. Right? And so,
God creating man,
because he's relational, he creates man
and offers himself where he's the best
thing to offer us. No nothing in this
world can compare. He offers us himself
and he allows us the choice to choose
him
or choose other than him.
Right? Which which leads to obviously
hellfire and destruction. Even in this
life, it just leads to turmoil and
distress and just everything goes wrong
when you're when you don't choose God,
you know? So,
um it's relationship. God is relational.
So, this is this is why he allows us,
even though he knows what our decision
is going to be in the in at the end, he
still allows us that choice and that
freedom to choose him or choose
otherwise because he's relational.
That's that's love.
Um
here's the second layer to this. The
second layer to this is is that God,
>> [clears throat]
>> knowing all things and loving us
despite,
he knows that we're going to sin. He
knew Adam was going to fall.
And he had a contingency plan
to fix what Adam broke.
He didn't just create the us knowing
that we were going to fall and fail and
corrupt the earth and mess up everything
and then just let it be. No, he knew,
"Okay, I'm going to create man.
It doesn't matter who I pick first. It
could have been Adam. It could have been
me.
All right, somebody's going to
somebody's going to fail.
Somebody's going to bring it all down.
So, what I'm going to do is is I have
this contingency plan
to fix it all,
which is Christ Jesus. I'm going to come
down, restore mankind, and restore
heaven and earth
to what it's supposed to be despite
this. And then we can live in a way
where there is no sin. There is no
destruction, no death,
no sin, no cursing, no none of that. All
of that is put turn is put away.
So, he has that plan. He does he does
he's not just going to leave us hanging.
>> [snorts]
>> You know?
So, I hope I hope that helps.
Yeah. I'll come on another time and I'll
we can talk about um like
cuz I want to talk more about Adam and
Eve and the fall and all that stuff.
>> For sure.
For sure. For sure. For sure. Well, God
bless you, Nakabi. Thanks for coming up,
okay?
>> [snorts]
>> Thank you. All right, you take care.
Thank you.
All right.
>> [sighs]